I worry that
we're all kind of disconnected.
Did you ask me something?
-What?
-It's fine.
-Okay. Good night.
-Good night.
CC, do you think
it's good for you to live like this?
Heads up.
Not supposed to use your hands.
Wyatt, family meeting downstairs.
Let's go!
Can you help me with this problem?
-I'm kidding. You can't help me.
-No, I can't.
We are gonna make
a happy memory as a family.
I wish you could be me.
I would love for you
to be me for one day.
I'd love for you to be me.
I'd kill to eat a dozen doughnuts
and just have it burn right off.
Would you take a picture
of my family, please?
Everybody say, "Merry Christmas."
-What are you doing in my bed?
-You're in my bed.
-Why am I in your bed, Mom?
-Why am I in your bed, Dad?
What is happening?
That's me.
-CC?
-Mom?
Wyatt?
Dad?
This is a situation
that has never happened before.
I'm 17 again.
-I'm 13 going on 30.
-So freaky.
What's wrong with Pickles?
What's going on with Miles?
Pickles is Miles.
We just need to get through today
and figure out how this happened.
Your dad happens to be the toast,
and high school's kinda my jam.
You stole my first kiss?
No! I… pulled away.
-You rejected Ariana?!
-God! Dad!
I can't believe
I thought we could pull this off.
-Be a boss. Uh-huh?
-Be a boss. Uh-huh.
Be a boss.
Sounds like you need
to fix what is broken.
We've got this. We're Walkers,
and Walkers never quit.
Cramps! Ow!
I think I tore a quadi.
More than anything,
I just want you to be okay.
We have 24 hours.
If we don't figure this out,
we'll be stuck like this forever.
This is the most exciting thing
I've done in years.
Whatever happens,
we'll get through it together.
This is just a dream.
And we have to wake up. Slap me.
I think the dog and the baby
are spending
too much time together.